improved information exchange and
intense cooperation between Europe and
ctg may ensure that we are ahead of
those who want to hit European continent
so I can say that the result of today
are more than satisfactory yesterday
evening I invited our colleagues
ministers for an informal dinner and in
an informal and open atmosphere we
exchange our views on my great migration
and asylum system reform we do anything
necessary whatever format it takes or
method it takes so that we have
compromised which is the main important
characteristics of the European policies
EDS will be quick chip but it will
vastly increase our knowledge over those
who come in and most importantly those
that should not one year ago as you all
remember i launched the EU internet
forum the foreign meets again here in
glasses on eight on the 8th of december
with the next J Council to take further
joint steps in effectively removing
terrorist material online on the
Schengen border code we're not far off
controls are part of a wider approach